and the stars of this viral clip are
demonstrating that big kitty cats like
to curl up in cardboard - I love this
next we need to try a giant ball of yarn
how do you watch Internet videos of
large cats you click on some links yes
we left - we've tracked the big cats to
Tampa Florida where their keeper Apted
Tassler told us why she's giving boxes
to lions we decided to do big cats and
boxes because we figured if domestic
cats like it that maybe the big cats
would like it and it's definitely worked
if you've seen the video ah but why do
cats like to curl up in cardboard the
big cats at the center have all been
rescued and to keep them occupied their
handlers have given them enrichment
enrichment is a term that scientists use
for anything interesting put into an
animal's area to keep that animal alert
and engaged in this clip there's kind of
two different sets of cats the ones that
are happy to get into the box and the
ones that are less happy to get into the
box and that breaks down into what
they're like in the natural world you
see some of the smaller cats like the
Lynx the Cougar the Bobcat getting into
the boxes and treating them like
shelters which makes sense because in
their natural environment they're not
the top predator so they often need to
find a place to hide from other
predators or to rear their young this is
quite unlike the behavior of the lion
and the tiger who are the apex predators
and are quite skittish of the boxes they
don't want to get into them but what
they do do is they rip them apart and
then eventually sit on them this
experiment seemed to go down really well
I mean even though they all reacted
differently towards the boxes they all
seemed to have a pretty good time so
basically here at Big Cat Rescue we like
to dedicate our lives to providing the
best possible quality of life for the
animals that we have because once they
come here we become their forever home
sounds perfect
we keeping your buddy